y confinamientos toques de queda
distanciamiento físico para algunas
personas con trastornos alimentarios
estos cambios continuos durante el
último año han provocado crisis o
recaídas para años el deporte y una
dieta estricta fueron un mecanismo de
defensa contra la pandemia con el
confinamiento ya que estaba trabajando
en jornada reducida no tenía ninguna
actividad durante el día
empecé una rutina deportiva incluso
diría que extrema hacía dos horas de
deporte al día empecé a reducir mi
consumo de alimentos cuando vi en la
báscula que seguía bajando me gustó
incluso empecé a probarme de ciertos
tipos de comida de ánimo tras un año de
pandemia los efectos negativos sobre la
salud mental son numerosos
el encierro todo junto empieza a ser
moralmente muy muy difícil uno pierde
las ganas el gusto por levantarte por
hacer algo tenemos la misma rutina y
sentimos que no disfrutamos de nuestra
familia no tenemos relaciones sociales
en el último año
muchas personas se han encontrado
aisladas y lejos del apoyo con el que
suelen contar
el resultado
un fuerte aumento de los trastornos
alimentarios como explica nathalie
godard el confinamiento y todas las
medidas en torno al coronavirus son
factores de estrés son fuentes de
ansiedad depresión también de trastornos
alimentarios que están muy relacionados
con la ansiedad y la depresión
el apoyo social algo que nos ayuda a
regular nuestras emociones a poder
intercambiar y que sucedió
particularmente perturbados sobre todo
para los adolescentes y los jóvenes en
francia cerca de 600.000 adolescentes y
jóvenes adultos padecen trastornos
alimentarios en algunos casos pueden ser
mortales incluso es la segunda causa de
muerte entre los jóvenes de 15 a 24 años
por eso se lee nicas decidió crear un
sitio web que pone en contacto a las
personas que padecen la enfermedad con
los servicios que ofrecen ayuda señala
que la pandemia ha dificultado mucho el
acceso a la atención médica
desgraciadamente la infelicidad y la
angustia de los pacientes que padecen
trastornos de conducta alimentaria han
aumentado sobre todo porque algunos
seguimientos han tenido que ser
interrumpidos en circunstancias normal
estos servicios ya están atascados hay
meses y meses de espera a veces años un
año un año y medio de espera pues bien
durante este período de confinamiento la
gente no tuvo acceso a estos servicios
por lo que algunas personas han sido
abandonadas a su suerte
justine vive sola en parís y durante los
sucesivos encierros sus trastornos
alimentarios se manifestaron se sintió
apartada de sus amigos y familiares y
conseguir la ayuda que necesitaba se
convirtió en una tarea laboriosa esa es
una de las cosas que me ha resultado
realmente complicada desde el
confinamiento me hace seguimiento una
psicóloga pero ya no tiene consultas
presenciales
así que le hablo por teléfono que no es
en absoluto lo mismo tener alguien
enfrente a sentir la presencia humana
tener un vínculo con la persona que te
sigue es muy importante francia vive
ahora su tercer encierro y las personas
con trastornos alimentarios siguen
sintiéndose tan aisladas como siempre
uno de los muchos aspectos del deterioro
de la salud
en medio de la pandemia